all right nicole is third time the charm
are you gonna
win with this one uh yeah i definitely
plan on being the first time
ever two-time winner you say that with
some confidence huh what makes you think
you're gonna win
um i think i have a little bit of
midwestern charm that i can bring
a little bit of sass a little bit of
feisty and then
i'm just gonna try to be myself and
establish for the first time ever like
real friendships and hope that takes me
pretty far i'm all about girl power
but what does el cuatro mean
it sounds like you're not going into
this with an intense amount of
manipulation or strategy you're gonna
play it real true
that's very true what's crazy is i think
everyone's gonna be going in
with so much manipulation and like cut
throat and
people are gonna need shoulders to cry
on and guess what that's gonna be me
and i'm gonna come off as genuine as i
can be
um try to be myself because in 18 i felt
a little like i had more to prove
and now i already won so it's like hey
back to myself and
let's win as me you know what's up
so right off the bat what are you
thinking i have no idea
what is your strategy coming in i don't
have a strategy
because i i can tell you one thing the
newbies want to stay together
what makes you think everybody's heading
into this with a lot of strategy on
their mind
i think a lot of people have to redeem
themselves i mean a lot of people have
played this more than once and haven't
won
and also you know i feel like a lot of
the big brother community has a lot of
like
stuff to prove as far as there's a lot
of
brawls on the internet and stuff and
like going on and so
i think that they're they're just ready
to fight
like i already won i'm good yeah i do
want to win again though but i just
think taking the more
like natural approach is better i don't
want to come in too hard too fast and
get knocked out right away
well what makes you want to come back
you're already a winner congratulations
nicole
you are the
[Applause]
so what do you have to prove well
nothing to prove really except for
i guess that i did deserve my winner in
big brother 18 i know some people
are like oh paul was robbed um he's a
great player don't get me wrong but i
definitely think i deserved it
but more so i'm doing it because i love
the game
it's i just love playing i don't think
i'll ever say no unless i have kids then
it'll probably be really hard to come
but this is probably my last time
playing i would regret so much
if i didn't say yes i just like i love
everything about it
the first hoh of the summer is always
huge but with this twist
you don't know being in the hoh is a
good thing
why is this your last time playing are
kids around the corner oh yeah i'm
hoping to
have kids we're getting married in
december and i'm hoping to start
popping them out right then an early
congratulations
thank you i was going to ask how has the
pandemic
affected the wedding what's the status
of things yeah so the wedding was
supposed to be in october
and it pushed it back to december and
now we're doing a destination in turks
and caicos so it's changed it completely
it went from
a wedding in michigan to now a
destination wedding which is what victor
wanted so
it's fine he won out okay
who will be there if anybody we're still
keeping our guest list
because i know a lot of people probably
won't be able to make that
trip and so i don't want to uninvite
anybody so whoever was invited the first
time is still invited
hey everyone it's time to pick players
for the first veto competition of the
summer
and how is it going to feel uh being
without victor in there
um it's going to be a little bit weird
going in knowing that
i don't have someone like victor who's
a great ally not only is he physically
strong and good in competitions
and keeps me like you know from freaking
out
um he's my partner in life so i'm gonna
have to find that in somebody else i'm
really looking for someone that's loyal
can do well in competitions and really
the number one thing is just i gotta
trust my gut
yeah well how does victor feel about you
going and playing without him
he's excited for me he never once was
like hesitant of
me should i say yes it was never a thing
he's like oh my god this is awesome for
us and our family
um he really believes in me he really
expects me to bring home that money for
our future children and future farms so
um yeah he's he's excited what will be
the plan if you win for that money you
said farm
yeah we're looking right now at a
farmhouse that we really love it's an
amish house so you have to we have to
put electricity and stuff into it which
can be pretty expensive
but it's beautiful and we want to have
like an animal
sanctuary to take care of i already take
care of a lot of animals
and you know having the budget would be
better and
more land more space and higher health
that's like the dream and then have
kids so that's what it would literally
be for um
i just i i really want it to happen and
you assume things
later on you it makes it fool out of you
right
yeah like you have to
you can't assume like we're not
[Music]
and was victor asked to be on two no he
wasn't
he actually wasn't he was a little bit
upset
that he's like i'm not an all-star and i
was like honestly
yeah i i think that you are an all-star
i was like it must be full of some
really good people
they're like you're an all-star in my
book honey
who did you have crossing your mind on
who you might see in there
who are you excited to see or nervous to
see i definitely think there'll be some
winners in there i'm expecting to see
uh casey probably which is pretty scary
because she
did really well on the challenge and
she's just a beast
um i'm expecting to see janelle i have a
gut feeling that and terry could be in
there and i think him and i could work
really well together so that would be
pretty amazing
maybe danny donato devon
i feel like i have so many people that
could potentially be in this
uh thing i don't know how stiff the
competition's gonna be
are you nervous yeah i'm i'm pretty
nervous i feel like i'm back on bb16
um you know going in a little bit shy
timid
instead of an 18 i was like these people
don't know what they're doing now i'm
kind of feeling like all right let's
humble yourself and let's uh go back in
with
nothing it feels a lot a lot different
than 18 definitely way more scared
yeah so since you are coming in with the
experience you have
and having been a winner how do you make
sure you don't just get
eliminated and become a target right off
the bat
that's a really good question i think
it's important to
seem like the least threatening winner
um i think we're all as winners who's
ever in there and has won the game is
going to have the same game plan of
maybe maybe actually we could stick
together and i could kind of go for an
alliance that way of like hey we already
all won
they might be coming after us i wouldn't
initiate that that's kind of bold but um
i think that's a good idea if if they're
all coming after us but
also just making myself seem as
chill personable relatable as possible
and not being like
i already won this game i feel like a
lot of people might shoot themselves in
the foot by uh
by not you know they think they're the
greatest player ever
now one thing i think that's new for you
is no opportunity for a showmance this
time right
definitely not definitely not we're like
hansel and gretel come on i don't even
know all these people
i think hayden is a lot of fun i kind of
had my mind set on nicole marrying a
farmer and not a pedicab driver like i
said i don't know if my best ally will
be a girl or a boy i'm just looking for
someone loyal and definitely
um no showmance whatsoever well how
might that affect you you know i think
it's actually going to be a really good
thing for me no distractions in that
aspect
and i think it's good to prove that i
don't need
a showmance to make me memorable in this
game
yeah and how will it be
missing victor like how much will he be
on your mind and how do you think that
might mentally and emotionally affect
you because
you you're probably coming off of you
know spending months together non-stop
especially in the quarantine
yeah i think it's going to be really
hard to be away from victor but i
do know i somehow get a little bit
stronger in the house where
as long as i don't think about home too
much and don't let myself
get sad i won't this is the first time
i'm going in though with a significant
other so i don't really know how it's
going to be i mean i already miss him
now
so i'm sure it will be hard but there's
other people that will
be going through the same thing um and
even worse with kids so
i just gotta kind of not complain about
it because this is a really cool
experience
and i know one day i'll be like oh i
miss this
what protocols did you have to go
through to make sure you were healthy
before entering the house in terms of
corona i'm a homebody
i personally just stayed home a lot um
and then now we are in complete
sequester
for two weeks as a vinyl could be longer
nobody's in and out wearing masks in the
house
we have one person here in case of an
emergency but very strict
um it's nice to not have a mask on for
once oh testing a lot of testing
my last question for you how do you
think the pandemic affects the game
and by that i mean you guys already go
through living in a house with just
these people but now everybody's coming
into it
having been quarantining for months the
the fear and the stress of corona of
kind of our political climate how do you
think that affects this season and what
will it be like
the season is definitely going to be
unique in the aspect of everything going
on in the world i'm not quite sure what
that exactly means i'm not sure if some
people are going to go even
crazier sooner as far as being locked up
because they've been locked up for
months and months
and i'm an introvert so for me it's
honestly
the best thing i i like to recharge with
a small amount of
people um but for the extroverts i think
that that can be difficult
and as far as everything else going in
the world i think that everyone just
needs to
really you know reflect on themselves
and reflect how they can be a better
person
and make sure that their true self is
what is being portrayed on tv
could this be the most intense season
ever
definitely going to be the most intense
season ever there's just
so many variables and you can never
prepare for this situation and that's
another thing with this
i know some people may have turned down
this opportunity because of
um things that we can't control and i
just thought you know what
just go in make the best of it and you
don't want to miss this opportunity it
could be the best thing that ever
happened to you you don't know
we can all grow and we can all learn